hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play insane hell
tour iam now this is an interesting game
that I found I don't know a lot about it
but from what I saw it seems like it
might offer something very unique ok
this game is in early beta and if not
alpha fixing and further development
everywhere blah blah blah that means
basically there's a lot of stuff here
that is very early as with most of these
indie horror games so get take it all
with a grain of salt
ok explore rooms find some notes from
Johanna and try to escape the insane guy
watch your noise and remember you can't
sprint forever oh you are a journalist
and a colleague of Johanna she had the
idea to write about an old abandoned
facility Sharn retreat that's one of the
authors of the rubric of for
Supernatural stories she loved to go
there you don't believe in such things
even more you find them boring you think
they are a waste of time and just have
one single purpose which is to entertain
the less intelligent readers you know
that this might seem a bit arrogant but
that's your opinion and it's final you
told Johanna that it could be dangerous
to visit such an old ruin of course not
because of any ghosts or other monsters
no because of the condition of the
building she might get hurt there you
care about her you like her maybe one
time you'll love her but you don't want
to rush things
Johanna seems like to like you too your
good qualities and got even closer over
time what is it what is that you makes
you sound like some kind of stalker guy
Johanna didn't give a damn about what
you were saying of course and she went
in that building you promised her if
anything went wrong she can always call
you she did not she's not home
you checked that no one heard from her
the past two days you have to check that
building you have to visit Sauron
retreat okay move flashlight run look
round pick up drop I got it
who was that amendment or wow that class
light is much different but that's a
great way to start it right off with a
mannequin front and center whoa is that
my body Oh something wrong with me beep
boop mark bot activated I entered the
facility still don't know if there's a
hospital or an insane asylum or
sanatorium or whatever it would be great
if I were given a bit more information
about all this don't know where to start
I'll look around a bit I'll try to keep
some kind of a map before plan this must
be something I should try the office
areas may well find one there well
alright then let's try I got it
I I don't see what they were talking
about with the noise level I don't know
what they mean that but when I saw from
the images and what I'm seeing right now
is egg this actually has quite a bit of
work put into it obviously early so I'm
gonna ignore the the model for the body
the fact that I can see myself walking
and animated it's pretty impressive as
it is just for a bare-bones skeleton so
I'm not gonna have to work whoa that's
cool I hold qo probably shouldn't be
slamming doors when I'm trying to escape
the insane guy that could use a better
name oh I really like that interesting a
little bit of immersion is never not
good what is these prison cells where
are they here why do they seem so
brightly lit and then when they get them
but not okay
I'm looking for notes from Johanna and
Johanna is my love you oh hey
it's really cool because they can
actually interact with a lot in the
environment that's something is lacking
a lot of these games interact ability
increases immersion by far it where's
that what is that there's someone else
there what is that oh it's just a lamp
wait I saw something on that wall over
there oh I thought that was like another
person just standing there but wait oh
that's so cool I can move it oh did I
just unplug it huh whoops
I broke it how do I let go of it let go
of it look on it the go of it oh come on
well I guess I got a lamp now maybe I'll
use it is it damn it you gotta be joking
me ah let go of it I'm pressing Q&E damn
it okay I guess I just have a lamp now
oh you come with me my friend you are
going to be my lamp body as we go
through this insane asylum but if insane
guy comes here I throw you and run like
little baby maybe I'll be able to pick
something else huh the wires going crazy
ooh be careful I have a lamp what is up
with that not yet available well alright
if you say so
hey stupid dude alright is this where it
came from
Jew buddy yeah the true buddy-buddy
rubadoux okay I made a loop I don't
think there was anything else over there
I'm just gonna take this lamp I love I
love lamp I love this lamp this lamp is
my best friend I don't think this is the
office areas anyway I need to get over
here I need to be careful by using my
sprint you okay buddy you doing good ah
what was that I heard something my mouse
went sticky for a second there maybe if
I could pick something else up like that
note was it a note are the notes gone
yeah man I just want to pick something
else up you're ready this
well I can open doors but I still have
my lamp you know what good I would never
want to abandon my lamb my lamp is my
love and my life
I call this lamp Johanna hello mr.
mannequin how are you doing today I
wonder if you have any other floor Oh
what was that
who's the spirit what is that that's a
thingy
what is that where is that I see you are
you the insane guy oh beware of my lamp
okay all right you just have a nice day
a few in the a and have a nice day it's
my new catchphrase that's what's gonna
be on all the new markiplier merchandise
is toilet there's another toilet where's
the ding dong damn off his areas hey hey
I really wonder if that was he insane
guy oh like just push him open okay oh
well alright then I'm actually gonna
turn up the volume a bit more I'd love
to play these or games with the volume
like cranked up to maximum Figg you're
not playing it a maximum volume you're
missing out man you gotta get it up you
gotta get it up and get it out alright
so I still don't see the noise level
they were talking about I mean oh I mean
I really don't I'm seem to just be
running or I seem to just be going
around everywhere I'm trying to bang my
lamp on walls but nothing one thing I do
have to say about this horror game is it
definitely has atmosphere and like just
feel to it you know there is you know
when you play a horror game you can
often tell when there's like the right
feeling in in this one's definitely got
is hard to nail down what it actually is
that is a koala
okay why is there this one chair right
here huh how strange I don't know why
this room gave me the heebie-jeebies but
it did what about seeing the chairs just
sitting there okay
fire alarm can't pull it till got my
lamp that's all I need
that's all I care about just me and lamp
going into it I mean of course it has
bugs but yeah I mean it's an early game
I can forgive this what am i doing where
am I going whoa wait what did it what
what is that oh oh oh oh no what oh oh
good oh hi you got a note on you
something is strange here strange
something strange here strange some
strange here strange earth strains here
strange stands here strange here ah
you moved why'd you move what are you
pointing at what are you pointing at are
you just are you a Nazi mannequin oh
okay all right I'm just gonna take oh no
it's not available yet oh no where'd you
go where to go it's gone we go we go
good what did you do with them where'd
he go
guys guys he vanished very concerned
about that
cuz it means why those mobile mannequins
I'm not gonna be very bad oh it's gonna
be one of those games
oh it's gonna be one of those games Oh
note ha I knew there had to be some kind
of playing around here I took with me so
I can easily check where I am God oh I
took it with me so I can easily check
where I am god I would definitely get
lost without it
oh I get it oh I will check where I am
god I would have been in long definitely
lost it's so dark here where this too
much actually wanted to use these notes
to keep track of important details for
my story now I'm writing about nonsense
okay well so long as guy got my lamp
friend won't let you you won't let me
why you will let me why alright oh good
pretty much everything is I won't let
you now oh oh yeah oh yeah oh oh who's
that who's that oh no it's the insane
guy protect my lap oh no oh no I hear
the insane guy lamp you're my only
friend in these dark times please
protect me oh oh oh
huh don't do that don't do that hmm what
was it God's ears
Oh Oh God don't blocked off so goobie
gabbard gaba goop goop goop goop where
am I supposed to go home I didn't get
any clues I didn't get any clues as to
where I was supposed to go oh I hear you
I hear you over there I'm just not go
over there oh did I find another no
while I was over in this area wait a
minute did I come this way oh I didn't
go this way okay man it's easy to get
lost in here I don't have a map I just
got my lamp that's all that matters
oh this is where I got lamp you want to
go back home lamp lamp you want to stay
here mmm I just got to get away from the
insane guy cuz I he's a bit of a problem
okay there's gotta be another place that
I can get something ah did I go down
this way I don't think I did hello oh
it's a dead end well that's useful all
right then
okay I hear that I hear that what is
that am I supposed to go to that or am I
supposed to run away from that what is
with this this is another dead end
what is with this what's the point here
lamp can you all right you know what no
I wouldn't go anywhere without my lamp
now I'm very protective of my lamp and I
think my lamp will protect me to protect
me right lamp really why is there a
bright light in this one why is there a
brighter
oh I don't know I mean I don't know I
don't think there's anything over here
I've kind of been everywhere in this
section of the place gotta be something
right the upstairs is blocked off maybe
there was something else over here that
I needed maybe something got unlocked
because I swear some of the Gabba goop
has disappeared from where it was before
I swear like either this doorway was
gobbed up no not this one
where'd he go where did my Friendly
Ghost go it's not in here anymore that's
good you know what maybe I shouldn't
care maybe I shouldn't be oh he's you
easier where is he where is he where is
he oh god these are physically
interactable that's a nice feature
Oh God ah you I you but this place is
that gobbed up still and still gob
double I hear you I just don't see you
so how about you go off off how about
that I don't know
I hear him over there wondering if I
could go to him ten that's really not a
good idea I wonder if I should go to the
insane guy that's trying to kill me I
don't know maybe I think that that's the
noise meter right there that's saying
like I'm making too much noise
but I mean it goes off if I walk and or
sprint is he hanging out in this one
again oh is hai insane guy Wow look at
you you're so weird and floaty
ah
oh you're not scary you're friendly you
want to play with my lamp I play with my
lamb hey my lamp is actually protecting
me hey how cool is that
no you Frankenstein wannabe you stay
away from me haha look at him go what is
he's doing what is he doing
done done
I'm Bom Bom my lamp really is protective
right now in its Valeria's hahahaha
suck on that oh well you lost interest
oh no oh no whoa no whoa all right I'll
let him that was a different zone all
right I'll let him kill me
hey what no kill me kill me bro oh he
can't kill me oh oh that's not yet
implemented ah oh but buddy buddy come
here come here
ahh friend ah come on
nah but yeah you're so scary with the
fact that you could in no way harm me
cuz your arms are bonded up and your
mouth is all gagged oh well you know
what you're terrifying to someone
you'll terrify someone someday I'm just
going to go home why can't you just
leave yet ha ha all right I think I
explored all that I meant to explore I'm
pretty sure I'm at the end of what this
game has to offer so I'm gonna end this
episode here this has a lot of potential
maker this game you did a real good job
there's a lot of little details here
that are really working in your favor
the atmosphere is great the exploration
is good the concept is you know kind of
kind of cliched but I mean still it's
not bad going into an abandoned mansion
Durst an insane asylum
it's been done but this has that that
little thing that it's hard to nail down
about horror games it actually is creepy
not that monster though he was scary at
first but you got a lot of stuff going
for year so we'll definitely work on
this I really I really like this so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye bye bye monster
a job
Oh
laughs
another intern
I'm ready I got right oh yeah